how was the CMAs man you guys got to go
dude congratulations too man and did you
yeah
congratulations Best New Artist was it
huh yes sir it was crazy man it was it
was really interesting cuz I didn't
think I had a chance to win it really
yeah man I mean is that true you didn't
think get all I did not at who you up
against I was up against Zack Bryan and
Parker McCullum right and I felt like no
all pun intended to my boy I felt like
Parker had a hell of a year and I feel
like Zach Bryan is the second most
streamed artist in country music right
now behind Morgan so it's like it to me
was a no-brainer and I'm such a Zack
Bryan fan like so the fact that I got to
sit next to him the whole night like
it's so funny we I'm glad you were able
to too yeah that was cool for me and him
to get that moment cuz he was awesome
dud I there was a moment where I
literally felt like me and him were like
tailgating and watching a concert
outside of an arena yeah you know like
he's over there drinking I'm ripping a
weed pin you know what I'm saying he's
cracking beers there's empty shot
glasses right there's empty shot glasses
under my SE he's got four or five half
drinking drinks under his every keeps
bringing him drinks and we're just there
talking about the music all night and I
just thought for sure he would win you
know the last thing right before they
announced the name was I think I tapped
him on a shoulder and said say something
nice about me or something funny you
know oh that's cool and then whenever I
uh uh I hugged him going up there I was
like man you you you deserve this you
know what I mean and then you looked at
him like don't worry I'll say something
nice I'll something I can do it now
don't worry but it was so it was really
cool and I had you've had this a lot in
your career but I was blessed for the
first time in my career to have a real
viral moment like I thought I'd went
viral before but it was like just
building to a real viral moment like for
whatever reason and I didn't touch my
phone for like 36 hours after the W show
because it was just such a big moment I
was just letting it sit you know and I
didn't want to have my phone on me that
night and everybody kept telling me man
you're going viral and I was like I'm
you know I'm like oh cool I'm thinking
check your bracelet to see if your
doctor's letting you
know I'm more concerned with
[__] that ain't a
whoop that's a that's a a aop on that
boy but so that was so wild and then
they was it really like you were just
shocked I was really shocked I really
didn't have a uh I didn't have a plan
walking up there I was just walking up
there like man I didn't you know I was I
was getting more excited as I was
getting up there adrenaline's pumping
I'm in the [__] bridgstone Arena I'm
on National Television dude I'm still a
white trash kid from Antioch all this is
like what the [__] is going on you know
what I'm saying like I'm not I'm not
jaded to this there's I'm not used to
this at this point in my career I'm
still like this is wild you know and I'm
standing up there and I'm like how many
steps is it up there like how high is
that how how is the stage it's like a
dude I didn't walk it but I bet it's
like 10 steps I tell you I didn't feel
them wow I was on the cloud Bubba you
know at that moment you're just like man
this is you know that would be the
scariest steps because then you know
once you get up there you have to turn
around and say something that would be
what was so scary no no I was just more
like you murdered that speech I was just
up there like thinking of my I was I
don't know what I was thinking I was
thinking like I tell you when I started
thinking was when I looked up and this
is inside baseball I like I have the
award I raise it up and I look straight
up and there's a teleprompter that's
going I'm not [__] you Theo 59 58 57
and I think to myself I got a lot to say
and a little time to do it I didn't
realize till I watched the speech
afterwards that I actually said that out
loud in that moment I was like I got a
lot of things to say and I'm going to
say it really quick huh but that was me
thinking out loud cuz I remember
thinking that that's the first time I
remember really thinking in that moment
was like oh [__] this is real I've got
58 seconds for they're going to start
playing the music on me and they're
going to send a Sandman from Apollo and
pull me I was like I better make this
count you know what I'm saying I knew in
that moment too I was like I'm
definitely not winning another award
tonight for
sure I'm G say it all right now I
definitely didn't think I was going to
win this one yeah you know and yeah I
just [__] fired dude it was the
coolest thing artist that's so cool
you're on a rocket ship bro dude it was
it it's funny I would think of any y as
new artists though in a weird way but
that that doesn't matter it's just it's
like a Accolade they do it doesn't
really matter what it is it's like
saying hey man uh people recognize you
in the exactly right it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter how long people people
have been winning that award that have
been around for a while but it is like
you on the map we recognize you see you
it's your time yeah and it is though I
mean I was giving you flowers out there
but it is true I mean everybody sees it
that it's just the lights are turned on
for you right now all the lights are on
for you right now I'm so stoked because
you do um and I've told you this before
you do such a good
job with your Podium that you're on and
giving back to this city and uh and and
the things that built you and it's just
I love knowing you as a fellow
nashvillian it's just Nashville is very
well represented thank you for sure no
it means a lot to me coming from y'all
especially but you guys are really the
you know some of the roots I know
there's a lot of guys around this area
you know but you guys are uh people that
if I mention like to people I'm like at
the gym with or something there's always
somebody that knows one of you guys you
know some of the guys that knew you
aren't usually doing too well I'll say
that but uh but they're good guys you
know hey that's funny true [__]
method cin let's go
boy I walked in here thinking I'm having
the biggest week of my career and
they're going to get me in trouble and I
was right
knew it dude I knew it the day of the CM
not to get weird and hokey but I walked
out of my front yard and my boxers in a
t-shirt no shoes no socks boxers now
neighbors driving by waving and I put my
bare feet in my front yard grass and I
just looked up at that son and I just
said a little prayer and I just thought
like you know what God I won being here
like I don't care if I win an award just
like help me to open the show let me do
it right let it be a moment you know
what I mean just like and let me enjoy
tonight like regardless man I set my
phone down at the house when I walked
out I didn't have my phone with me I
didn't check my phone till the next
night you know what I mean like I was
present in every situation and because
of that I think when I got on that stage
and scene 58 57 something inside of me
was like you thank God you thank your
wife you thank your label and you say
something that [__] matters is what
was going through my mind you know what
I mean cuz that was that presence of
like I was just so grounded in the
present of that moment I knew then that
moment wanted to thank Parker McCullum I
knew I wanted to tell Zack Bryan I
thought he was the goat and I knew I
wanted to tell my wife I loved her and I
knew that I wanted to say something that
would at least make a [__] go
man he blessed me with that you know
what I mean and I didn't think it would
do what it did I was up out of my seat I
saw a silhouette of me just
like as you elevated I was like [__]
[__] yeah I had tears in my eyes bro I
was I mean the the faces on the audience
all around me some were like oh my God
some were like some were in tears I was
literally you would have thought Derrick
Henry just took off for a 98 yard
touchdown run I was losing my mind and
you're a vessel that's that's you know
be being a tour or whatever being a
vessel like I think when you are that
present
and that in tune nobody's more of a
vessel than I think than you jelly you
know I think you really do I think you
inspire so many of us man you know there
just yeah you just have a gift I don't
even know if it's a gift for you be it's
like it's not a gift that you have but
it's just it's a gift that you are right
you know feel like a gift I think to so
many people you know and you know what I
love about you the same dude that could
say something that eloquently just
thought Cameron Haynes was the underwear
guy you know what I'm saying like that's
what makes Theo
though